ja ich begrüße zur heutigen sitzung in
der wir uns nochmal mit immanuel kant
beschäftigen werden und bevor ich jetzt
auf immanuel kant eingehe und sein
zeitverständnis möchte ich noch mal
diesen netten herren hier vom letzten
mal mit seiner großen langen zunge ihnen
präsentieren und ein paar zitate von
albert einstein ihnen vorstellen die
sein verhältnis zur philosophie
betreffen also er hat sich da nämlich
ein bisschen ausgelassen über
philosophien ich habe diese zitate aus
einem sehr empfehlenswerten buch das ich
ihnen kurz mal zeige dass es gar nicht
groß es ist einfach diese sind diese
rowohlt monographien und das ist
neuauflage eines schon seit längerer
zeit erschienenen bandes in dieser reihe
nicht alle rowohlt monographien sind
gleichermaßen zu empfehlen aber die ist
es also da kriegen sie wirklich auch
noch einen sehr guten einblick in seine
ideen geschichtlichen umstände die auch
dazu beigetragen haben dass er zu so
bedeutenden erkenntnissen gelangen
konnte und jetzt habe ich aus diesem
buch ein paar zitat heraus die sein
verhältnis zur philosophie betreffen ist
ja nicht klar ist albert einstein
philosoph wahrscheinlich nicht hätte
sich sicherlich nicht als einer gesehen
wie sage ich bin ein theoretischer
physiker aber das verhältnis von
theoretischer physik in dieser
tiefendimension wie sie albert einstein
unternahm und der philosophie ist doch
sehr eng und jetzt habe ich ein paar
zitate als er sagt das interesse an
philosophie war bei mir immer da
das ist also schon mal schon mal ganz
nützlich zu wissen er hat sich immer
schon für philosophie interessiert und
dazu passt auch folgendes zitat das
schönste was wir erleben können ist das
geheimnisvoll ist es das grundgefühl das
an der wiege von wahrer kunst und
wissenschaft steht
das ist das geheimnisvolle würden sie
das noch anders umschreiben mit
philosophischen begrifflichkeiten das
geheimnisvolle
haben sie noch einen anderen begriffe
das geheimnisvolle dem wir begegnen
können inwiefern ist das geheimnisvolle
philosophisch relevant ja
ja also das war es nicht sich uns direkt
da bietet in den sinnen
da kommt zu einem metaphysische
dimension rein
aber schauen sie doch einfach auf dieses
grundgefühl es gibt noch ein anderes
phänomen oder anderes wort das mir diese
mit so ein grundgefühl des
geheimnisvollen zusammenhängt auch ja
die intuition denke ich auch ich will
jetzt verborgenheit genau das was wir
entbehren also was verborgen liegt und
wieder auffinden können also es war ein
geheimnis was entdecken können ist es
noch ein anderer begriff sie werden
gleich darauf gekommen ist das wunder
also die verwunderung muss ich genau
gesagt dass das sich wundern muss ich
schreiben weil das ist ein
philosophischer begriff des wunders sich
wundern wenn ich das wunder sondern dass
sich wundern das erstaunen weiß jemand
von ihnen wie das auf griechisch heißt
dieses sich wundern da kommt auch platon
ständig darauf zu sprechen
ich schreibe es mal in dieser umschrift
steht das thema 10
ich muss noch mal ein bisschen anders
schreiben
dass sich wundern
als sich wundern was heißt sich wundert
wie würden sie das sich wundern mit
anderen worten mal noch mal beschreiben
warum ist der philosoph platon und auch
nach mir vielleicht bestimmt auch nach
vielen von ihrer meinung einer der sich
wundern können muss man gehört dass sich
wundern zur philosophie was für gründe
könnten dafür sprechen
warum ist ist nicht der ein philosoph
nach der meinung vieler der alles weißt
eh immer alles weiß die immer sagen
immer eine antwort parat hat warum ist
gerade das sich wundern
vielleicht philosophischer als das
wissen ja genau also also dazu gehören
zwei komponenten erstmal zu wissen dass
man noch nicht weiß sokrates sagt ich
weiß dass ich nichts weiß und darin
besteht meine philosophie als sich sein
nichtwissen eingestehen weil viele
glauben zu wissen und wissen es
eigentlich gar nicht es ist ja erst mal
ein bisschen peinlich
sag ich mal einzugestehen dass man etwas
nicht weiß ergibt sich eine blöße
aber das sagen viele philosophen und
sokrates und einstein obwohl er
vielleicht jetzt nicht im strengen sinn
des wortes ein philosoph ist würde das
auch unterschreiben dass sich
eingestehen dass man etwas noch nicht
weiß das ist die bedingung dafür
um überhaupt mal wissen zu können und
dazu gehört eben auch dass man sich
überraschen lässt und dass man dinge
nicht für bare münze nimmt oder anders
gesagt dass man dinge hinterfragt und
dass man sich über die kleinen
unscheinbaren dinge des alltags wundern
kann dass man sich zum beispiel fragt
könnte das nicht auch ganz anders sein
warum ist das denn gerade so könnte es
nicht auch sich anders verhalten und da
beginnt dann die philosophie und da
beginnt dann auch wie wir bei einstein
gesehen haben die theoretische physik
wenn sich ein stand fragt könnte ich
nicht auch einen willen einer welle
nicht weil ich hinterher rennen mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit da wird jedoch
stehen bleiben von könnte es nicht sein
dass es eine maximale geschwindigkeit
könnte es nicht sein dass zeiten eben
bewegten systemen die zeit langsamer
verläuft also alle sich für bare münze
das scheint mir hier so eine grund
grundtendenz zu sein und dann hatte auf
die frage ob seine lehre mit derjenigen
kannst in widerspruch steht mal
geantwortet dass es schwer zu sagen
jeder philosoph hat seinen eigenen land
wie auch immer das zu verstehen ist als
er war durchaus ein bisschen ironisch
und dann sagte aber noch über immanuel
kant folgendes ich lese hier unter
anderem kann's polycom ina die polygone
ist eine anschrift an ein werk von und
fange an fange an die ungeheure
suggestive wirkung zu begreifen die von
diesem kerl ausgegangen ist und immer
noch ausgeht wenn man ihn nur die
existenz synthetische urteile apriori
zugibt ist man schon gefangen
immerhin ist es sehr hübsch zu lesen
wenn auch nicht so schön wie sein
vorgänger jung der auch bedeutend mehr
gesunden instinkt hatte also sie kennen
alle alpaka jaspers schon mal gehört
karl jaspers und albert einstein wie sie
wissen lehrte die am ende seines lebens
in princeton und es war mal die frage ob
karl jaspers einen ruf nach princeton
erhalten solle
also ob er dort aufgenommen werden
können
und dann hatte man albert einstein
befragten dazu etwas zu lesen geben von
karl jaspers und er meinte also das sei
nur sinnloses geschaffen was die
erstmals von sich geben also welche zu
unterschreiben aber jedenfalls mit
immanuel kant konnte er etwas anfangen
und noch mehr mit der ewig jung warum
der irrtum weil der video 1 amp er ist
fan der eben auch sich sehr kritisch mit
bestimmten begriffen wie kausalität
befasst hat als wir sehen hier albert
einstein ist philosophisch durchaus
informiert gewesen orientiert gewesen
und in diesem betonen des
geheimnisvollen dieses sich wundern
können es ist er ganz nah an den
ursprünglichen tugenden und
einstellungen der philosophie so viel
noch als abrundung der letzten sitzung
haben sie noch bemerkungen fragen
die albert einsteins theoretische
philosophie betreffen also ich glaube
wir haben uns jetzt auch fast zwei
sitzungen seiner physik da gewidmet und
sie können ja alles noch einmal
nachhören auch mit diesen folien
ich glaube dass das jetzt ausreichend
ist um jetzt weiter zu gehen oder
anzuknüpfen
an diesen netten herren hier an immanuel
kant und zwar nicht an seine pro lego
minar also schrift von der jetzt albert
einstein im vorherigen zitat sprach
sondern an seine kritik der reinen
vernunft die im jahr 1781 erschien und
die seinem hauptwerk ist die darf sein
haupt als sein hauptwerk gelten und in
dieser kritik der reinen vernunft hat
kant eigentlich alle wichtigen ideen
seiner gesamten philosophie grundgelegt
und seine philosophie nennt man
transzendentale philosophie
transzendentale philosophie weiß von
ihnen jemand was es mit einer trans
zentral philosophie auf sich hat also
tanzen dental darf jetzt nicht
verwechselt werden mit tanz tendenz ist
also keine transzendenz sowie die
transzendenz philosophie wäre eine
philosophie die sich mit dingen
beschäftigt die überhaupt nicht
gegenstand unserer erfahrung sein können
weil sie so erhaben zum beispiel sehen
wir jetzt nicht gott also es gibt
sicherlich alten also in der hebräischen
bibel und andere schriften so darstellen
wo war gott erscheint in einer gewissen
weise aber es ist immer so dass wenn man
etwas sieht von gott dass man dann so
geblendet ist und zb es gibt die stelle
von mose wo er gott sieht und dann aber
so geblendet ist dass er das denn
eigentlich gar nicht richtig sehen kann
aber zb der gegenstand das thema der
begriff gottes wäre es ein gegenstand
der metaphysik also von einer entität
oder eine realität die eben übersinnlich
ist die uns nicht im alltag durch unsere
sinne begegnen kann ja so erhaben
und das wäre als eine transzendenz der
gegenstände die gar nicht in unserem
sinne fallen können weil sie unsere
empirische wahrnehmung prinzipiell
übersteigen und das möchte kann gerade
nicht möchte ich keine transzendenz
philosophie sondern er möchte eine
transzendentale philosophie und trans
zentral heißt er geht nicht über die
erfahrung hinüber als wenn jetzt dass
die erfahrung ist
dass die erfahrung dann wäre das die
transzendenz das geht über die erfahrung
hinaus und die bewegung der des
transzendentalen die geht vor die
erfahrung und nicht über die erfahrung
also man könnte sagen die geht
gewissermaßen nach unten
was heißt es jetzt genau dieses nach
unten gehen als es geht darum die
erfahrung wird nicht überstiegen
das wäre die transzendenz der erfahrungs
und die erfahrung wird überhaupt
begründet also man fragt sich nicht was
übersteigt die erfahrung ist wenn man
fragt sich was macht überhaupt die
erfahrung möglich
was müssen wir voraussetzen als
notwendig damit wir überhaupt dinge als
solche wahrnehmen erkennen können dass
ich sagen kann
dies ist ein stuhl hier steht ein stuhl
dieser stuhl ist rot dieser stuhl ist
gelb was ich sagen kann gestern war das
wetter so und so dass ich mich zeitlich
orientieren kann das mich räumlich
orientieren kann
das sind alles bedingungen der
möglichkeit von erfahrung also das sind
die bedingungen bedingungen der
möglichkeit von der farbe sie sehen wenn
das bedingungen der möglichkeit von
erfahrung ist dann ist es nichts was
jenseits der erfahrung liegt also über
die erfahrung hinaus geht sondern etwas
was vor der erfahrung liegt was
erfahrung erst möglich macht und in
diesem kontext dessen was erst möglich
macht besteht auch seine befassung mit
der zeit also zeit ist nichts was wird
direkt in der erfahrung erfahren was so
wahrgenommen wird da ist die zeit und
hier nehme ich sie war
man müsste sich sowieso fragen mit
welchem sinnesorgan man die zeit war
nimmt genauso das ist übrigens auch mit
dem raum auch die raum ist nichts im
raum was wir wahrnehmen sollen wir
nehmen die räumliches war zeitlich und
räumlich es war aber das zeitliche und
das räumlich ist nicht der raum und die
zeit als solche wir nehmen nur
zeitliches war weil es da die zeit gibt
zeit als eine bedingung alles zeitlichen
überhaupt genauso wie der raum als
solcher ihr könntet wird sich hier
wieder erinnert fühlen an newtons
begriff des absoluten raumes und der
absoluten zeit wie auch eben räumliches
nur durch den raum als solchen möglich
ist und sie sehen schon dieser raum als
solcher durch den erst räumliches
möglich ist ist natürlich auch einer
ganz anderen ebene angesetzt
als erfreulich ist man muss sich das so
vorstellen dass die bedingung der
möglichkeit von erfahrung er ist schon
eine art rahmung ich habe das letzte mal
so ein bisschen angedeutet dass sie sich
das bei kant alles mit solchen rahmungen
oder formen vorstellen müssen also nach
kant haben wir erst mal bekommen uns
noch näher darauf zu sprechen sind es
daten also das ist so ein schönes
eindrücke die ich mir zu klein bisschen
darstelle also wir haben wir haben wir
haben gerüche wir haben wir haben ein
tastsinn also passt gefühle tastendrücke
wir haben visuelle eindrücke ich sehe
hier geld ich sehe hier schwarz und so
weiter diese bezahlen sinneseindrücke
haben wir akustische informationen das
seien jetzt mal solche klein
ziehen die müssen uns von außen gegeben
sein die können wir selbst nicht nach
cannes produzieren das wäre könnte nur
ein intellektuelles arche typus ich
erkläre oder kant erklärt nachher noch
was das genau ist also ein bildender
verstand der selbst praktisch die sinnes
daten selbst generieren kann
das können wir nicht wir können zum
beispiel nicht sagen ich will diesen
stuhl jetzt hier gelb wahrnehmen obwohl
er schwarz ist ich will jetzt davon ich
will jetzt das er gelb ist es geht nicht
also ich bin darauf angewiesen auf die
die sinne des qualität dieses studie und
das ist jetzt eben mal schwarze oder
dass ich jetzt will dass dieser pult
jetzt weich sich anfühlt dass er jetzt
weich wird es geht nicht deshalb habe
und dass dass er so und so ist diese
diese basalen sinneseindrücke also wie
hätte ich schreibe es mal hierhin als
beispiel härte härte farbe geruch
gesehen hat ist der tastsinn farbe ist
der gesichts sinn der sehsinn größte
geruchssinn und auch nach der gehör sind
also ton thron
die hängen alle von unserem sinn ab und
die müssen uns wie kann sackt im bearish
gegeben sein und dieses gegeben seien
durch die erfahrung nennt kann taucha
postareal also erst durch die erfahrung
werden uns sind es daten vermittelt und
was kann aber jetzt sucht ist das was
vor alle erfahrungen liegt also was die
bedingung der möglichkeit von erfahrung
ist was also nicht die erfahrungen
steigt was nicht in der erfahrung liegt
also das ist sondern er sucht das was
vor alle erfahrungen klickt und das
nennt er jetzt apriori apriori heißt
einfach vom vorhergehenden
von vorderen vom früheren hier früher
jetzt natürlich nicht zeitlich
verstanden sondern logisch und
erkenntnistheoretischen also was muss
vor allem erfahrung schon liegen damit
wir wirklich erfahrung haben können im
strengen sinne wohl jetzt ist natürlich
erfahrung noch nicht alles hier gehörte
farben und gerüche töne wahrzunehmen das
ist jetzt ein moment einen moment ein
bestandteil von erfahrung aber erfahrung
ist natürlich immer ein sinnvoller
zusammenhang von gegenständen
das ist dann kann dieser stuhl und hier
ist noch nicht die rede von stuhl oder
von form
hier ist nur die rede von farben von
qualität dieses stuhles oder dieses
pools oder was auch immer
und kann möchte jetzt mit einer ganz
komplexen theorie
unsere erfahrungen begründen in dem er
jetzt auf zeigt was alles vor der
erfahrung liegt also wir haben
einerseits nach kant sinnes daten das
ist austria haben gerüche usw
und wir müssen aber auch noch formen
haben die diese materie kann zeigt auch
dass es zu materie die materie formen
wenn ich nur irgendwelche
freischwebenden gerüche oder frei
schwebenden sinnes daten habe damals ein
schwarz klecks ihr sohn roth klecks da
komme ich nie seine erfahrung
ich muss ja sagen können meine erfahrung
ist dass dieser studie
schwarz ist und dieser studie ist gelb
das heißt das geld findet sich hier
geformt das geld befindet sich einem
bestimmten ort das geld befindet sich in
einer an einer substanz nämlich der
stuhl ist gelb und dass ich solche
sinnvollen erfahrungs aussagen tun kann
damit ich das tun kann brauche ich eben
auch hier diese diese ab yogischen
momente das ist hier apostel
das heißt es muss noch ein paar formen
dazu bringen das ist das was kann dann
durch solche rahmungen veranschaulicht
also diese ganzen x10 diese sind es
daten
die finden immer nur geformt treten nur
geformt auf und werden nur in einer
geformten form sondern jetzt mal zu
einer sinnvollen erfahrung eine form die
diese sind es daten annehmen müssen
die diese sind gebracht werden müssen
hier ist schon mal raum und zeit
sie muss sagen hier jetzt da ist der
stuhl und dieser stuhl jetzt hier dort
ist gelb das ist eine erfahrung
erfahrungssatz und das heißt sie müssen
hier immer noch weitere rahmungen oder
formen
das sind jetzt formen um diese materie
herum schachten diese formen sind die
betreffende dieses transzendentale alle
formen in denen solche sind es daten
auftreten können
die sind apriori die betreffend die
bedingung der möglichkeit von erfahrung
da sitzen wir also ganz kurz und ganz
knapp genaue struktur struktur genau zum
beispiel genau also zum beispiel farben
oder oder töne oder härten die wir
wahrnehmen sind an sich noch
unstrukturiert die liegt irgendwo vor
aber ich kann jetzt nicht sagen dieser
stuhl ist gelb allein von deck des
allein auf basis des gelb eindruck so
dass ich sagen kann dieser stuhl ist
gelb dazu muss ich eine struktur
voraussetzen dazu muss dieses urteil
auch strukturiert sein und diese ganze
struktur die bekommen wir durch solche
rahmen zb dass ich sagen kann dieser
stuhl
dazu muss ich einen begriff verwenden
voraussetzen den begriff den substanz
substanzen aktie dance der stuhl
substanz ist gelb gelb ist ein akzidenz
gelb ist eine eigenschaft die jetzt
nicht im wesentlich ist der stuhl könnte
auch rot sein er könnte auch schwarzer
dass ich so als sinnvolles urteil fällen
kann erfahrungs urteil muss ich eben
eine struktur mit hineinbringen und
diese strukturen sind betreffend dieses
transzendentale dieses ab rio rische
dass es vor allem erfahrung und sie
betreffen auch die form
zum beispiel könnte jetzt hier eine form
die substanz sein
eine weitere form die zeit um eine
weitere form der haube das sind alles
formen substanz zeigen auch wenn
zeitraum von einer anderes artigkeit
bezüglich der form sind als es zum
beispiel die substanz ist der begriff
der substanz genauso verhält es sich
nach kant auch mit dem begriff der
kausalität und sie zahlen kann
verursacht b das ist etwas was ich einer
form verdammt und nicht das ist es nicht
so dass uns kausalität sinnlich gegeben
ist im bearish gegeben ist ich kann
einem verhältnis in der wirklichkeit
nicht äußerlich ansehen allein aufgrund
des sinnes daten dass hier kausalität
frühling ich sehe immer nur den adern
bmw und das ein paar mal ganz
schließlich draußen h ist die ursache
von b aber dass das eine notwendige
verknüpfung vorliegt das sah nicht nur
immer vorbei vorher geht und b aufbau
erfolgt sind dass das asb hervorbringt
und gewissermaßen verursacht oder nötig
das sehe ich den bloßen ereignissen in
der welt nicht an also eine weitere form
hier wäre dann eben auch noch hier so
was wie kausalität
wir sind alles alles strukturen das
alles top-qualität substanz zeitraum und
sofort alles schachtel um diese basalen
sinneseindrücke herum die kant auch
materie nennt und die uns ab post
ergeben sind als erst durch erfahren und
nicht vor allem
und diese ganzen formen jede strukturen
sind vor allem sind formen die apriori
sind die bedingung der möglichkeit von
erfahrung bedeutet das jetzt noch mal
ganz allgemein ist natürlich ein riesen
ding und das ist auch für ein bachelor
sind ja eigentlich noch viel zur
voraussetzung voll aber wir wollen uns
jetzt hier nur einen aspekt fand der
ganzen kantischen kritik der reinen
vernunft hier annehmen nämlich derzeit
theorie und lesen jetzt mal hier die
fragen die wir uns stellen wollen
nämlich was versteht kann oder eine
transzendentale ästhetik wie definiert
kann die zeit die hatten auch schon 14
mal gestört diesen fragen und worin
unterscheidet sich ganz zeitverständnis
von demjenigen newtons und leibnitz fans
wissen sie noch mal kurz wie die
theorien bei leibnitz und bei juden
waren was sagten die über die zeit
einmal ganz kurz weiß man ihn noch
jemand was sagt den youtube newton ist
vielleicht einfacher was man tut mir ja
es gibt genau es gibt eine absolute zeit
war die frage wie stellen wir uns diese
absolute zeit vor schwierig
also ich hab immer so den vorschlag dass
man sich das irgendwie verheimlicht
vorstellt wie so ein gefäß zumindest den
absoluten raum kann man sich so
vorstellen
die absolute zeit verrinnt nach newton
gleichmäßig sie ist diese absolute
hintergrund an dem alles konkrete
zeitliche gemessen werden kann
und das stellt natürlich ein bein stellt
in frage
absolut zeit verrinnt nicht überall
gleich sind die zeit verrinnt umso
langsamer je schneller sich das system
bewegt das heißt nach einstein wird so
was wie eine herbst oder zeit
problematisch wir haben uns das so
vorgestellt wie so eine wäre also eine
absolute wie seiner zahlenreihe die
einfach absolut gleich getaktet ist und
innerhalb derer wir oder durch die wii
jedes ereignis bestimmen können
der absolute bezugspunkt der zeit ich
stell mir das sowieso eine total
gleichförmige bevor er spielt jetzt
erstmal gegenwart vergangenheit zukunft
keine rolle
diese aspekte werden davon abstrahiert
sind einfach nur dass die zeit existiert
und dass sie gleichförmig verläuft und
zwar nicht an bestimmten punkten
schneller oder langsamer in bestimmten
episoden oder soja und was sagte dagegen
leibnitz wissen sie das noch das war ein
bisschen schwieriger sagt jetzt leibnitz
bekommen wir zeitliches jetzt hier nach
links in die welt
ja nicht so ganz zu sagen und schon der
existenz genau
genau leibnitz geht dann eher auf die
dinge oder noch genauer vielleicht auf
die relationen von dingen also die
bezüge in denen dingen stehen die
konstituieren erst zeit man könnte
vielleicht nach moderner begrifflichkeit
sagen dass zeit nach leibnitz ein epi
phänomen ist als etwas das erst auftritt
wenn wir eine bestimmte konstellation
von dingen oder ereignissen haben da war
natürlich jetzt die frage wie kann man
sich denn jetzt relationen zwischen
dingen vorstellen die so sind das aus
jenen zeitlichkeit entspringt haben sie
eine idee was das eine mögliche relation
ein kandidat wäre
ja wachstum würde diese relation
implizieren also zb kausalität
kausalität
so stelle ich mir das jedenfalls
vorbereitet sagt da nicht so viel drüber
mit diesem brief ex mit klage also
kausalität
das würde auch im wachstum einschließen
also chaos erlebt oder zum beispiel auch
so eine zweck ursächlichkeit oder causa
finales das wäre wachstum also dass da
irgendwie was angelegt ist in diesem
ding dass dieses ding mal ein baum
werden soll also mit dieser oder
irgendwie also ein natürliches also ein
keim ja dass ein keil in diesem keim ist
schon angelegt dass da mal irgendwelche
pflanze entstehen soll
da wäre dann so eine technologie
angelegt und durch diese technologie
würde dann auch die zeit irgendwie
kommen ich stelle es mir so vor dass wir
einfach zwischen dass dinge in kausalen
relation stehen
anna ist die ursache von b und dass aus
dieser logischen relation aus dieser aus
diesem logischen kontext in dem die
dinge stehen und zwar ganz bestimmt
stehen leibnitz hat alles seinen grund
dass durch diese verbindung der dinge in
der welt durch gründe
durch diese totale kausale determiniert
hat das als die ursache von b sein muss
und nicht die ursache von a ist also
durch diese asymmetrie asymmetrie der
dinge in der welt also wenn a die
ursache von b ist dann ist b nicht
ursache von a sind alles hat eine
richtung
also a und b ist wiederum die ursache
von c
das ist jetzt die kausalität dann habe
ich durch diese asymmetrie asymmetrie
meint einfach dass dieses verhältnis
sich umkehrbar ist wenn ich sage hat
bewirkt dann hat nichts bewirkt sondern
ist eben b die wirkung die wirkung von a
das eben durch diese kausale richtung
also hier in dieser richtung dass wir
dadurch eine einen zeitlichen effekt
erhalten so stelle ich mir das wenn wir
eine kausale richtung haben dann kann
sich das kausalen urzeitlich entfalten
natürlich kann man sich jetzt fragen
wieso mussten sich kausalität zeitlich
entfalten könnte nicht auch alles auf
einen schlag sein sagte sie diese frage
fragt sich zum beispiel david hume
woraus geht hervor dass bis jetzt fünf
sekunden nach erfolgen muss woraus
folgen das warum muss kausalität
überhaupt zeitlich sein es könnte doch
so sage ich sage ich habe einen zeit
schlag ein kleines zeit moment und
diesem zeit moment wird die ganze
qualitäts reihe von a bis unendlich
durchlaufen hier könnte man natürlich so
so argumentieren dass man sagt ja gut
aber das unendliche kann nicht in einem
einem winzigsten zeit durchlaufen werden
das geht nicht die kausalität frei ist
potenziell unendlich und deswegen muss
kausalität zeitlich ausgedehnt sein so
könnte man argumentieren ja man könnte
auch sagen dass der begriff der
kausalität sinnlos wird weder nicht
irgendwie eine abfolge in sich schließt
und man könnte schließlich noch sagen
dass die kausalen glieder hier so
unendlich klein sind dass sie in ihrer
unendlichkeit eben wiederum zeitliche
ausdehnung hervorbringt haben so wie
eben auch immer kleinere zahlen gibt
kleinere teilchen gibt die aber dennoch
dann in ihre unendlichkeit größere teile
konstituieren als momente her
kommen
ja durchaus eben als ich würde halt
sagen ein solcher kausalität schritt von
a nach b könnte so könnte man es so
vorstellen aber eben nicht bis jetzt
hier sei es mit seinen unendlichen wir
können uns schlecht hier das ganze die
ganze kausalkette die die welt
durchziehen
ja also bei kleineren verursachen kann
bringt das beispiel wenn wir zum
beispiel eine kugel auf ein kissen
liegen in ein kissen liegen dann ist
dieses ablegen der kugel und die welle
die das kissen bekommt diesen zur
gleichen zeit sein kann dass eine werte
eindruck als eine werde
es wäre sein eindrucks verhältnis ich
drücke das ein und mit dem loslassen der
kugel mit dem auf das kissen fall geht
die delle einjährige die einwirkung
dieses kissens einher so kann man sich
schon vorstellen wenn sich das beispiel
eine billardkugel kugel hingegen
vorstellen wo eine kugel auf eine andere
trifft und die dann wieder eine andere
und so weiter naja gut sie kennen alle
dieses sie kennen alle diese dieses
spiel wo man hier oben kugeln aufgehängt
hat sie kennen das sowas und jetzt lenkt
man hier eine aus und die fällt jetzt
hier da dran und kennt es und dann geht
der ganze kausal stoß und die hier geht
die hohe wenn wir jetzt eine kugel
loslässt was passiert dann geht nur die
letzte hoch sie kennt das wenn diese
aufgehängt sind solche kugeln und dann
könnte man auch sagen gut die kausalität
und zwar könnte man jetzt diese kette
der kugel hier unendlich lang machen
unendlich langen und es wäre wohl so
behaupte ich jetzt nur gut dass sich die
jetzt wäre die frage da bin ich ganz
sicher wie diese kraftübertragung hier
wie lange die braucht wenn jetzt diese
reihe kugeln sehr lange es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten also wie die
lichtgeschwindigkeit dass die
informationen nur mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit mehr auftreten kann
oder dass eben einfach
ja da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher wenn
jetzt sehe ich diese kette ganz lang
vorstellen wie lange
wenn dann die erste kugel her auftritt
wie lange es braucht bis die letzte dann
aus gelenkt wird
das spannende frage aber zumindest in
solchen kleineren sachen geht mit dem
auftreten der ersten kugel mit dem
aufprall geht wie hoch das heißt da
haben es in den eindruck diese
kausalkette die sie dadurch setzt weil
die natürlich auf die drückt die drückt
auf die idee das ist praktisch gut wie
null zeitlich 0
ich frage mich jetzt eben grad wenn
jetzt hier unendlich oder sehr sehr
viele kugeln hier dran sind
ob dann nicht ein bisschen mehr zeit
vergehen muss aber das ist eine andere
frage aber sie sehen man kann sich so
etwas vorstellen
jedenfalls sagt leibnitz nein kausale
information kausale übergänge sind nur
zeitlich möglich als aus den folgt
letztendlich so eine art von ausgedient
haid und daraus entsteht dann die zeit
ja wir wollen also vor allem uns jetzt
hier mit eben dem verhältnis zu newton
befassen und ich kann schon vorwegnimmt
das kann im grunde genommen der
newtonschen der nude visions physik
weiter an hängt aber das ganze jetzt
nicht mehr objektiv ist ish betrachtet
als ob es da die zeit gibt es gibt hier
einfach die absolut zeit sondern kann
bindet die absolute zeit an die
bedingungen unserer erkenntnis und das
heißt letztendlich an unsere erkennende
subjektivität hier gibt es nämlich noch
so eine form die um diese
sinneseindrücke rummachen muss nämlich
hier die äußerste frau das ist das eine
transzendentale ich dran denn brutales
ich das ich ist auch noch so eine form
die auch und diese ganze sinneseindrücke
umgelegt wird also lauter formen lauter
schachtel ungen und alles apriori um
diese postareals durch erfahrung gegeben
ja also es gibt eine gewisse logik
das ist ganz spannend also man kann die
zum beispiel fragen kommt jetzt erst
raum und zeit wohl schon also damit
überhaupt kausalität stattfinden kann
muss erst raum und zeit gegeben sein
kann man sich fragen ja kommt erst zeit
und raum wird erst raum derzeit kann
wird erst die zeit und dann der raum
die zeit ist weil es eine feine
anschauungs form wie wir doch gleich
sehen werden des inneren sinn es ist
immer zuerst da es könnte nämlich sein
dass wir nur innerlich erfahrungen
machen und keine äußerliche wenn sie zum
beispiel die augen schließen die ohren
sich zu heben
dann können sie sich dinge vorstellen
innerlich leute sie können zum beispiel
mathematische operationen vornehmen
zum beispiel können sie eine rechnung
machen drei plus 3 und das wäre nach
kant etwas was in der zeit stattfinden
müsste die rechnung weil sie nämlich in
der rhein an chance form derzeit sagen
zeit punkte oder zeit stellen
aufaddieren also 3 + 3 sie müssen so
einer reinen zeitformen sich das
vorstellen nach kann und dazu brauchen
sie kein raum das geht allein derzeit
deswegen würde kann sagen ja also die
zeit ist ganz ganz vorne dran dann kommt
der raum und dann scheint mir dann
würden
die anderen kategorien kommen wie
substanz kausalität da wird es dann
spannend was kommt jetzt erst kommt erst
substanz dann kausalität ich würde sagen
er ist die substanz weil wir können von
kausalität nur dann sprechen wenn ein
ding was eben substanziell sein muss ein
anderes ding verursacht also es wohl so
dass erst die substanz kommt muss
logisch trans and a low gestanden die
kausalität
dann aber gibt es wieder die andere
kategorien wie einheit vielheit usw
dann ist die frage die reinheit und
substanz sind ja sehr verwandt märz ein
ding ganz ganz spannende frage welcher
logischen verhältnismäßigkeit diese
ganzen trans zentralen formen hier
stehen
hegel zum beispiel würde sagen kann hat
diese logischen formen nicht ihre
wirklichen notwendigen abfolge
konstruiert er hat das irgendwie
willkürlich gemacht also die ganzen
logischen formen sind verkannt würde
hegel sagen sie sind bei kant noch nicht
überzeugend in einer entwicklungs logik
dargelegt worden
deswegen hat hegel die sogenannte
wissenschafter logik geschrieben wo er
für jede kategorie kausalität substanz
raum und zeit zeigt dass sie sich in
einer ganz bestimmten logik auseinander
entwickeln zb beginnt das bei hegel es
wissen sie wahrscheinlich mit dem sein
dass sein steht ganz am anfang als der
begriff des seins ist der erste begriff
und dann folgt das nichts und dann folgt
das werden der begriff das werden und
aus dieser ganzen die ganzen logik
entwickelt sich dann im laufe der zeit
entwickeln sich immer konkrete reformen
wie im raum und zeit hat irgendwann auch
mal erkannt hat dasselbe was hegel von
ihm gesagt hat über aristoteles gesagt
weil sie kennen die kategorien lehre von
aristoteles bestimmt schon mal gehört es
gibt zehn kategorien also die hexe die
lage dass das wie viel das also bei on
und und so also solche bestimmten grund
betrifft gibt es auch schon aristoteles
und dem hatte dann wiederum kant
vorgeworfen dass aristoteles diese
ganzen kategorie nur willkürlich
aufgezählt haben es gibt dieses dieses
dieses diese
dieses die substanz gibt es auch aber an
welcher stelle die kommt bei aristoteles
sagt jetzt kann ist völlig unbegründet
und deswegen entwickelt canzone
kategorien lehre und hegel entwickelt
alle kategorien lehrern wird dasselbe
kann vor was kant aristoteles
vorgeworfen hatte als sehen es eine
spannende frage diese ganzen ab rio
rischen begriffe wie reden wie eben
substanz kausalität natürlich auch zeit
obwohl zeit und raum nicht auf derselben
ebene wie substanz und qualität
angeordnet sind da kommet gleich darauf
zu sprechen
derzeit sind nach kant dinge oder
gegenstände oder phänomene die der trans
and arlen ästhetik zuzurechnen sind habe
ich ihn ja in der zusammenfassung
geschrieben das trans zentrale ins tätig
nicht mit schönheit verwechselt werden
darf
was ist denn die trans zentrale ästhetik
wissen sie das machen
genaues ist betrifft also unsere
wahrnehmung ja also und zwar die
transzendentale ist tätig betrifft die
bedingung der möglichkeit von unserer
sinneswandel hat also nichts mit
schönheit heutiges im engeren sinne zu
tun und da in dieser trans and arlen ist
tätig da dort haben raum und zeit nach
kann ihren ort und jetzt haben wir das
schon mal gelesen ich lese aber trotzdem
noch mal vor wir werden jetzt einmal ein
paar weitere zitate lesen immer hier auf
unsere an unsere aufschrieb hier
beziehen er sagt auf welche art und
durch welche mittel sich auch immer eine
erkenntnis auf gegenstände beziehen mag
es ist doch diejenige wodurch sie sich
auf dieselbe unmittelbare zieht und
worauf alles denken als mittel ab zweck
die anschauung
diese findet aber nur statt sofern uns
der gegenstand gegeben wird dieses aber
ist wiederum uns menschen wenigstens nur
dadurch möglich dass er das gemüt auf
gewisse weise offizieren die fähigkeit
rezept ivi tät vorstellungen durch die
art wie wir von gegenständen tapeziert
werden zu bekommen heißt sinnlichkeit
vermittelt der sinnlichkeit also werden
uns gegenstände gegeben und sie allein
liefert uns anschauung durch den
verstand aber werden sie gedacht und von
ihm entspringen die begriffe alles
denken aber muss ich es sei geradezu
ohne umschweife vermittelt gewisser
merkmale zuletzt auf anschauen mithin
auch bei uns auf sinnlichkeit beziehen
weil uns auf andere weise gegenstand
gegeben werden kann
das ist wiederum hier
dieses schema sinnlichkeit heißt wir
sind auf diese x10 angewiesen auf härte
farbe geruch und ton
wir können diese qualitäten selbst nicht
hervorbringen
ich kann nicht sagen ich möchte jetzt
einen gelben tisch dort sehen
es geht nicht an gelbe sturm geht mir
der stuhl ist schwarz die schwarz das
schwarze muss mir gegeben sein das steht
nicht zur disposition
das sind diese zahlen sind genauso wie
ich schon sagte dass der pult das pult
dass das hart ist das wird jetzt nicht
weich wenn ich mir jetzt wünsche dass es
reicht
ich bin darauf angewiesen dass ist nach
kant diese wurzel unseres denkens und
des erkennens unseres wahrnehmens und in
letzer hinsicht können wir alles was wir
wahrnehmen und auch erkennen
zurück führt auf solche päckchen
teilweise als immer unsere erkenntnis
und unsere wahl hat hat es immer
letztendlich mit solche nix zu tun auch
wenn sie nicht darin aufgeht dass mit
der sinnlichkeit sinnlichkeit wie gesagt
nicht wie im heutigen sinne genommen
sinnlichkeit ist heute enger verstanden
sinnlichkeit meinte damals einfach nur
die sinnes daten die wir machen können
und dann sagt er hier noch was die
fähigkeit vorstellen durch die art wir
uns gegen wie wir von gegenständen
avisiert werden zu bekommen
und das nennt er die rezepte wie theta
letzte aktivität heißt einfach nur da wo
wir passiv sind da wo wir aufnehmend
sind wir müssen irgendwie die sind es
daten geliefert bekommen wir nehmen sie
wahr und dieses wahrnehmen ist die
rezeptiven darin besteht aber nicht
allein erkenntnissen erkenntnis besteht
immer aus zwei teilen aus wahrnehmung
oder rezept ivi tät und auch noch aus
spontanität spontanität heißt dass wir
hier selbst aktiv werden und wir werden
aktiv durch diese kategorien wie
kausalität substanz
arbeiten jetzt geht es gleich weiter
sagte die wirkung eines gegenstandes auf
die vorstellungs fähigkeit sofern wir
von demselben avisiert werden ist
empfindung diejenige anschauen welche
sich auf den gegenstand durch empfindung
bezieht heißt empirisch der unbestimmte
gegenstand einer empirischen anschauen
heißt erscheinung in der erscheinung
nenne ich das was der empfindung
korrespondiert die materie derselben
dass ich nicht aber welches macht das
das mannigfaltige der erscheinung in
gewissen verhältnissen geordnet werden
kann nenne ich die form der erscheinung
oder auch die struktur könnte man sagen
da das worin sich die empfindungen
allein orden und gewisse form gestellt
werden können nicht selbst wiederum
empfindung sein kann
so ist uns zwar die materie alle
erscheinen nur aproz theorie gegeben die
form der selben aber muss zu ihnen
insgesamt im gemüte apriori bereit
liegen und daher abgesondert von alle
empfindungen können betrachtet werden
das war's abgesondert von alle
empfindungen empfindungen ist eben das
hier härte farbe tun genau das was
abgesondert von diesen bisschen
betrachtet werden können muss das ist
nach kann das was gegenstand der
transfer tal philosophie ist das sind
diese ganzen rahmungen und die ganze
formel ist eine ganze philosophie dreht
sich letztlich um diese formen die
kausalität substanzen zeitraum ja
ja
genau bei der bei der beschwerde bei den
bestimmten gegenstand kommen dann noch
weitere kategorien spiel also zum
beispiel jetzt dieser stuhl dass ich
sage diese kommt die substanz nach mit
ins spiel
also es geht jetzt erst mal nur
allgemein darum was überhaupt empirisch
gegeben sein kann
hier kommt ja noch viel weitere viele
weitere kategorien mit ins spiel allein
strukturen das ist praktisch denn noch
strukturlos ist so würde ich das
internet ihre erscheinung eben weil wir
hier angewiesen sind auf die
sinneswahrnehmung das was erscheint das
was wir durch unsere sinne wahrnehmen
die müssen letztendlich auf sich auf
erscheinung zurückführen lassen
dann werden sie aber weiter angereichert
durch solche kategorien wie kausalität
substanz und zeit
es gibt natürlich verkannt auch noch
andere gegenstände die jetzt nicht
empirisch sind das gibt es auch noch ne
aber das ist jetzt erst mal ein
gegenstand der auf die erfahrung
zurückzuführen ist der durch die
erfahrung konstituiert wird
gewissermaßen
gibt es hier noch bestimmter gegenstand
er stellt sich das jetzt eben so vor
dass jetzt ein bisschen bisschen
schwierig vorzustellen
das sagt also die wirkung eines
gegenstandes auf die vorstellungs
fähigkeit also man muss sich das so
vorstellen da gibt es jetzt einen stuhl
oder irgendein objekt in der welt und
das nehme ich war durch meine sinne und
das heißt diese x10 hier die müssen
irgendwo herkommen
diese müssen irgendwann kommen kant
spricht zum beispiel auch von einem ging
an sich das ding an sich das ist etwa
das wäre zum beispiel ein bestimmter
gegenstand das ding an sich wäre sagen
der grund für diese extreme woher kommen
denn diese ganzen sinneseindrücken sie
kommen ja schon von dem gegen irgendwie
her
sie müssen ja irgendwo herkommen sie ist
sie müssen einen grund haben aber damit
ich den gegenstand dann ganz bestimmt
erkennen kann
reichen diese aktien nicht aus und es
reicht auch nicht aus zu wissen dass es
da ein ding an sich gibt dass hinter
diesen ganzen sinnes daten steht das
wäre doch sehr unbestimmt damit ich
sagen kann dieser stuhl hier ist schwarz
dazu brauche ich diese ganzen anderen
kategorien hier als ein bisschen ich
gebe ihnen recht ist ein bisschen ein
bisschen schwierig formuliert aber wir
brauchen uns jetzt erstmal nicht an
solchen einzelnen begriffen festzuhalten
auch wenn sie wie sie völlig richtig
sagen wichtig sind also was hier wichtig
es ist dass er sagt hier
das worin sich die empfindung allein
ordnen lassen und formen dargestellt
werden kann ist nicht wiederum selbst
empfindung also diese formen wie
kausalität substanz und zeit und raum
die sind nichts ist die die sind nichts
was wir wahrnehmen können
wir nehmen nicht die kausalität war
wir nehmen so was wie ursächlichkeit
nicht wahr
wir nehmen auch so was wie zeitlichkeit
nur nehmen wir nicht wahrnehmen
zeitlichkeit dies im empirischen sinne
eigentlich nicht korrekt gesprochen war
ja
wir werden
scheidung von ihr ein mehr als
überschaubar aus diesem verhältnis von
gestellt
ja es ist ein guter punkt also ich lese
es so dass eben dass die unbestimmte
gegenstand das ist was der grund dieser
sind es warm ist die müssen irgendwo
herkommen und die rottöne die uns die
ganzen teams daten sie müssen ihren
grund in etwas haben diesen grund kann
ich aber nach kant letztendlich nicht
erkennen
sie sind einfach gegeben und ich kann da
nicht weiter fragen durch was jetzt
genau begibt sie sind einfach da und
wenn ich dann aber konkretere aussagen
treffen möchte wie zum beispiel dieser
studie ist schwarz dann brauche ich
etwas was nicht durch die erfahrung
gegeben sein kann nämlich so was wie
form und das wiederum macht dann aus
dass ich diese sind es daten in solche
ordnung bringen oder auch strukturen
wir lesen mal weiter noch gleich aber
sie noch ja
[Musik]
nein nicht ich habe es einfach jetzt mal
so hin geschrieben das war die frage des
kommilitonen also ich würde sagen dass
wir eigentlich sagen müssten also wir
können sie mal konkreter machen auch
wenn das jetzt sehr weitgehend ist ich
versuche es mal nach meiner auffassung
korrekt zu machen aber das sind ganz
ganz schwierige fragen die über das
seminar thema eigentlich hinweggehen
ich würde sagen hier kommt erst die zeit
dann kommt er dann kommt die substanz
und dann kommt die kausalität ist
natürlich jetzt nicht vorstellen es gibt
noch viel mehr kategorien aber worauf
hinweisen möchte ist raum und zeit die
sind nicht auf derselben ebene wie die
substanz und qualität das hat gibt sie
sagen zwei blöcke sagen
hier kann man auch noch ein paar andere
sachen hinzu aber so wäre es erst mal
korrekt dass also erst die zeit kommt
und dann der raum
das sind strukturen das sind alles tun
was in dieser logik muss das ganze
formal gedacht werden
jetzt können weiter ich nenne alle
vorstellungen rhein im trans and arlen
verstande in denen nichts was zu
empfindung gehört angetroffen wird
danach wird die reine form sinnliche
anschauung überhaupt im gemüt apriori
angetroffen werden worin alles
mannigfaltige der erscheinung in
gewissen verhältnissen angeschaut wird
diese reine form der sinnlichkeit wird
auch selber eine anschauung heißen so
wenn ich von der forschung eines körpers
das was der verstand davon denkt als
substanz kraft teilbarkeit im gleichen
was davon zu empfindung gehört als
undurchdringlichkeit härte farbe usw
besondere so bleibt mir aus dieser
empirischen anschauung noch etwas übrig
nämlich ausdehnung und gestalt diese
gehören zur reinen anschauung die
apriori auch ohne einen wirklichen
gegenstand der sinne oder empfindung als
eine bloße form der sinnlichkeit im
gemüte stattfindet das müssen wir jetzt
mal ein bisschen genauer noch mal
anschauen weil hier wird jetzt dieses
modell hier weil sie jetzt hier an die
tafel gemalt hat das wird jetzt hier
erklärt in diesem kurzen zitaten also
was sagt er
also wenn ich von der vorstellung eines
körpers das was der verstand davon denkt
denken sie sich als vorstellung des
körpers dieser schwarze studie
das heißt halt mal die vorstellung auf
dem sie sitzen jetzt können sie von
diesem stuhl verschiedene von diesem
körper des stuhles verschiedene momente
abstrahieren
zum beispiel können sie sagen ich denke
mir jetzt etwas weg von dem stuhl
nämlich seine substanz die substanz
nehmer zweck der stuhl ist eine substanz
kann ansprechen also ein subjekt noch
weg die kraft und die teilbarkeit alle
zum beispiel dass ich den stuhl jetzt
sehr segen könnte ich könnte ein stuhl
immer weiter zulegen kleine teilchen
wir können so was im kraft könnte man
jetzt sagen ist eine art kausalität auch
wenn der stuhl natürlich jetzt nicht
kausal wirksam ist aber man könnte
wiederum sagen der studie hat eine
gewisse kraft hat eine widerständigkeit
usw substanzen
manche das wichtigste wenn ich das jetzt
wegnehme von dieser von dieser
vorstellung des körpers dann kann ich
natürlich auch noch auf der anderen
seite war es weg nehmen nämlich aus
dieser seite ericsson nicht kann
wegnehmen als abstrahieren von dieser
vorstellung des stuhles dass er hart ist
ich kann die farbe abstrahieren und
meinetwegen auch noch den geruch weder
den riecht bestimmt nach holz oder nach
farbe oder so was ja wohl nachdem vor
wenigen der zuvor drauf saß
das ist ein guter punkt da sind dann
einbringen dass es nach kant nicht so
und das ist das interessante von cannes
kann sagt also ich kann mir denken dass
ich die substanzielle form wegnehme und
dann bleibt aber immer noch das schwarz
übrig das schwarz haftet dann nicht mehr
an einer substanz aber es ist dann auch
so ein bisschen was ich dann habe das
ist die these von kante ist ein bisschen
das ist also da damit steht und fällt
die kantige theorie könnte man sagen
dass so was nach kant logisch möglich
ist ich kann die struktur wegnehmen
ein stuhl ist und ich hab die farbe nur
weil die farbe einer anderen wurzeln
springt als die substanz das sind zwei
verschiedene zwei verschiedene sage
jetzt mal kategorien
die substanz ist eine reine form
betrifft das formale und die farbe
betrifft unsere wahrnehmung sind also
völlig verschiedene erkenntnis stimme
die den gegenstand konstituiert
also sagt es also wir können
abstrahieren jetzt kann ich eben hier
noch die die den bruchweg neben meinem
wegen der ton noch usw haben alles weg
und was bleibt uns noch übrig das ist
übersteht ist es jedoch stehen geblieben
in dieser strichliste
seitenraum genau deshalb kann also
selbst wenn ich den blick die struktur
der substanz wegdenken kann ich gar
nicht von dem gegenstand sprechen
gegenstand kann genuss sagen wenn ich in
substanz habe habe ich kann sagen da ist
noch härter da ist noch geruch da ist
noch schwarz wahrnehmung und wenn ich
das auch noch wegnehmen würde kann dann
ist immer noch was übrig geblieben
nämlich wie er sagen würde hier so
bleibt mir aus dieser empirischen
anschauen noch etwas übrig
etwas übrig hier nämlich ausdehnung und
gestalt als er sagt das ist ein bisschen
komisch er sagt also dass selbst wenn
nicht die kategorie der substanz weg
nehme ich immer noch ausgedehnt habe
normalerweise könnte man sagen ja mit
dem weg nehmen der substanz habe ich das
ausgedehnte schon mitgenommen als er
denkt substanz nicht als etwas
ausgedehnt dessen substanz biologisch
substanz als die bedingung der
möglichkeit der zu- oder absprache von
bestimmten qualitäten dass ich sagen
kann
dieser stuhl ist schwarz damit mache ich
keine aussage über seine ausgedehnt hat
damit mache ich nur eine aussage über
das logisches objekt also den adressaten
gewisse eigenschaften den bezugspunkt
gewisse qualitäten zu sagen dieser
studie gelb damit mit der substanz tue
ich nur aus dass ich etwas habe dem ich
etwas zu sprechen kann ist dieses geld
ein subjekt seien in der sprachlichen
der syntaktischen struktur geben dann so
ein super dem ich ein prädikat zu
sprechen kann es interessant weil es
könnte ja auch substanzen geben die
nicht vielleicht räumlich sind nicht
zeitlich sind es möglich zb engel oder
so engel wären jetzt vielleicht zeitlich
aber sie werden vielleicht einräumen ist
die frage oder wenn man von gott spricht
oder wenn man von wie auch immer es
scheint mir nicht notwendig so zu sagen
dass substanzen ausgedehnt sein müssen
also räumlich ausgedehnten müssen also
substanzen logischen sinne zu verstehen
dass sich einer sache etwas zu sprechen
kann und damit muss die sache nicht
freue mich sein und sagte also wenn ich
das dann bleibt noch was übrig nämlich
ausdehnung gestalt als in diesem falle
raum wäre das jetzt natürlich zeit auch
noch diese gehören sagt jetzt kann traum
ausdehnung dahin zuzuführen fügen wäre
noch zeit gehören zur einen anschauen
die apriori auch ohne einen wirklichen
gegenstand der sinne oder empfindung als
eine bloße form der sinnlichkeit im
gemüse stadt führt
das wäre ein bisschen schwierig weil
stoffliche und materielles immer schon
wenig rechtliche ausgedient gedacht
werden müssten
also wer also es gibt nichts materielles
was nicht ausgedient ist und dieses
dieses ausgedehnt sein das ist verkannt
etwas was dem raum dem traum zuzurechnen
ist eine substanz muss wohl ganz ganz
logisch gedacht wird dieses objekt
stelle in einem satz im subjekt dem ich
etwas zu sprechen subjekt subjekt
prädikat objekt oder wie auch immer das
objekt brauchen jetzt noch nicht hier
sondern nur subjekt prädikat reicht der
blick ist die substanz im prädikat wären
dann eben alles solche dinge wie die
divise sinnes daten betreffen also diese
ganzen x10 sind das prädikat und die
substanz ist zum tag sind taktisch
gesprochen einfach die subjekt stelle
auf die wir bestimmte prädikate beziehen
können oder eben im urteil des sagen
kann dieser stuhl ist so dass einfach
nur den urteils funktion
deswegen ist sagt auch kann dann das
wird jetzt auch zu weit die ganzen
begriffe wie substanz usw
die betreffen unsere urteile struktur
unsere urteils tafel sein kann
also wir urteilen des weges substanz
verkannt er seine logische funktionen
eine logische funktion von bezügen und
relationen das ist so aber eine gute
frage dass stellen und deswegen sagt es
kann okay wenn wir das alles abziehen
dann bleibt uns noch raum und zeit übrig
also zeit sagt jetzt hier nicht er sagt
ist ja nicht nur raum ausdehnen
gestanden
das ist und das was noch übrig bleibt
das muss jetzt und das ist die front das
darf jetzt selbst wiederum das kann
jetzt selbst wiederum nicht sein was von
dieser iks struktur ist wir haben die ja
alle abgezogen
das heißt es ist etwas was ab rio risch
ist was also vor alle erfahrung
stattfindet die ausgedehnt hat natürlich
kann jetzt frage aber kann ich
ausgedehnt halt nicht nur durch sinne
und so wahrnehmens erkannt nein also
dieses faktum des räumlichen ist nichts
was ich jetzt empirisch durch sinnes
daten wahrnehmen obwohl es etwas ist wie
er sagt was zur sinnlichkeit gehört aber
es ist eben die form der sinnlichkeit
es gibt nach cannes zwei arten verformen
und formen sind wir kann immer apriori
es gibt eine form die unseren verstand
betrifft das sind die dinge die wir
logisch erkennen zb substanz des urteils
struktur beschreiben
das ist eine form des verstandes die
apriori schiss und jetzt gibt es noch
eine form der seligkeit die auch ab rio
risch ist die aber nicht zum vorstand
gehört weil sie keine logische urteil
struktur bezeichnet und diese
aperiodische form der sinnlichkeit ist
eben gerade der raum und die zeit und
das ist sondern das ist das neue bike an
damit steht und fällt also etwas a
priori sches und das war bei newton wenn
ich es recht zäh nicht der fall also der
absolute raum ist nicht a priori sches
der absolute raum ist auch was
wahrscheinlich nach newton ab ostsee rio
ist es einfach etwas was wir durch
erfahrung erkennen es halt dieser
absolut und der absolut zeit nächster
halt gibt in der welt die wir ja auch
irgendwie erfahren kann
obwohl die rede von absoluten raum remy
nahelegt dass es so eine form ist
innerhalb dessen sich alles erst halten
kann und dann wenn wir wieder ganz nah
bei kann ich will das jetzt mal offen
lassen ich bin keine newton experten
aber newton hätte damit denke ich keine
probleme gehabt ob jetzt der absolute
traum apostel jorisch oder prior ist das
wäre für ihn egal gewesen für ihn wäre
nur wichtig gewesen
das ist ein absoluter raum gibt und der
absolut zeigen dass die gleichmäßig
verläuft in welcher hierarchie die trans
zentral angesiedelt ist würde für ihn
keinen unterschied machen
eine entwicklung des
die möglichkeit nicht der möglichkeit
von erfahrung von zionisten also wir
können sind es daten wahrnehmen
letztendlich nach kämpfen können sie
isolieren unabhängig von der substanz
wir können einfach nur so ein rot
eindruck haben
stellen sie sich vor sie haben ein rotes
gesichtsfeld und gelbes sondern homogen
gelb ton da es noch nicht von der
substanz die rede als gedacht dass diese
ganzen dinge als logisch unabhängige
momente gedacht werden können jetzt
endlich also es ist so dass dies sind
unabhängig sondern logisch unabhängig
voneinander
ich kann mir wirklich sondern sie können
ja verstehen sie habe nur sein ton oder
sie haben einen totalen homogen grün
eindruck also die ganz gesichtsfeld das
ist deine perzeption ist nur grün haben
sie haben sie bloß und so denke ich muss
man sich das vorstellen
ja auch eine gute frage das ist so ein
begriff der bei kant etwas unklar ist
gemüt würde ich sagen ist ist unser
erkenntnisvermögen würde ich sagen also
letztendlich unsere erkenntnis apparat
man könnte jetzt auch sagen unsere seele
aber kannte hat grosse probleme mit dem
seelen begriff
es ist einfach unsere erkennen der
subjektivität zufließen
subjektivität ist weil es bist unsere
erkennen der subjektivität
weil nämlich und ist noch wichtiger
punkt es gibt ja noch das trans zentrale
ich was alles dann um greift also alles
von dem wir sagen können wir erkennen es
von dem können wir immer sagen ich bin
ist er es erkennt ich bin die es
wahrnimmt
wir können von allem was uns vorkommt
immer sagen ich bin es die jetzt diese
erfahrung hat in letzter hinzu da ist
steht immer noch so ein bisschen dieses
ich bin es der oder die und das meint an
dieser letzte äußerste rahmen das ist
also der letzte rahmen und man könnte da
so ein bisschen in diesem gemüt das
damit dass ich was diese sind es daten
hat das ist dass ich was die reine
anschauungs formen der des raumes und
derzeit mit ins spiel bringt aber der
gemüts begriff ist bei kann selbst nicht
näher definiert das ist so ein
bezugspunkt das ist einfach die
subjektivität die das macht als wir
letztendlich als als erkennen gewesen
unser gemüt jahr
das eine spannende frage also kant würde
sich selbst als ein transzendentalen
idealisten bezeichnen denn thaler
idealismus kann man es nicht mehr gut
lesen
trans zentrale idealismus bedeutet dass
sowas wie raum und zeit und wie substanz
und kausalität dass die nicht unabhängig
von dem erkenntnis objekte existieren
und insofern könnte man sagen dass eben
ein gewisser teil der außenwelt seine
seine seinen grund im projekt hat aber
er ist jetzt nicht in diesem sinne ideal
ist also sagen würde dass wir zum
beispiel auch das rot und des gelb
selbst produzieren deswegen wäre kann
kein absolut ideal ist also erkannt es
haben manche kann so gelesen dass als ob
die ganze außenwelt unsere erfindung
während unsere produktion wäre als wir
erzeugen sozusagen die ganze welt in uns
das wäre nach das wäre nicht zutreffend
weil wir eben so was wie rot und schwarz
und hart und weich nicht selbst uns
erzeugen das ist dann immer die
realistische wurzel bekannt diese ganze
nixon
wir müssen uns gegeben sein woher auch
immer kann sagt sondern ging an sich was
auch immer das ist ganz schwieriger
punkt aber das ist das anti
idealistische moment oder anders gesagt
das realistische moment bekannt dass
diese häkchen farben usw
dass die nicht selbst aus unserer
subjektivität kommen das ist das ist
praktisch das was uns ab post harry orie
geben zahlen muss und kann sagt wir
haben beide momente wir haben etwas was
wir selbst erzeugen das ist das stark
idealistische moment das oder was uns
mir selbst mitbringen das sind diese
ganzen formen hier zeitraum substanz
kausalität dieses
und dann gibt es aber eben noch diese
x10 und nur im zusammenspiel von
realistischen momenten das sind die
sächsischen das ist sein realismus dem
tourismus können wir sagen und diesen
idealismus der aber nur diese rahmungen
betrifft alles was den rahmen ist könnte
man sagen ist kann man transzendentalen
nennen also dran zentral ist alles was
den rahmen um diese x10 bildet das ist
ein cent an
alles was diese rahmung betrifft ist
nach kant idealistisch zu nennen als es
eben vom subjekt abhängt aber kannte
mich damit nicht sagen dass jeder eben
seine eigene welt sich so konstruiert
von was die substanz und die zeit
anbelangt sondern und das ist jetzt aber
ganz schwierig da noch zu zeigen kann
sagt insofern es sich hierbei um trans
zentrale rahmungen handelt sind die auch
inter subjektiv und objektiv möglich
also es hängt nicht von unserem
individuum absolut kann denkt das sehr
stark objektives tisch
in ahlen das ist zur existenz der dinkel
möglich
dann werde ich alles was zur tat seien
diese bestimmung haben wollen ist dass
wir alle also genau diese gehindert im
verhältnis allezeit verhältnisse
erscheinen allein bestimmt werden können
ist alles im jahr erscheine das ist mir
das reale
vielen dank also das zeit- glaube ich
noch mal schön dass es eben in logische
funktion ist die substanz einfach das
substrat das was übrig bleibt wenn wir
von diesen gegenständlichen
eigenschaften absehen wenn wir von rot
und blau und solchen dingen absehen
dann bleibt eben erst mal nichts übrig
aber jetzt können wir wieder die
substanz noch wegnehmen und dann bleibt
eben noch einen raum übrig und das ist
die große entdeckung sozusagen oder die
frage ist ob es einen deckung ist aber
die große theoretische leistung die welt
so zu denken dass raum und zeit
unabhängig von der substanz sind also
wir haben dann eben noch die den raum
und die zeit übrig nämlich als diese
eigens um getesteten apriori shen formen
die jetzt aber nach kant ebenso sinnlich
kam erzählen das ist die sinnlichkeit
und wollen wir jetzt denken wir sind
lichkeit ist doch dass hier kreuzen sind
doch die sinnlichkeit sein kann ja sie
machen die sinnlichkeit aus aber nur
material und es gibt auch noch eine
formale sinnlichkeit und die formale
sinnlichkeit betrifft in rauen zeiten
ist praktisch die formale kann man nicht
mehr los und das ist die materie also
materiale sinnlichkeit die aixigo
das ist eine wirklich spannende
entdeckung der formalen sinnlichkeit als
raum und zeit und die zeit ist eben
einfach mal eine form der sinnlichkeit
erkannten dass auch die reine anschauen
eine anschauen eine wissenschaft von
allen prinzipien der sinnlichkeit a
priori das raum zeit nehme ich die trans
zentrale ästhetik brands and all das was
vor alle erfahrungen möglich ist das
abrutschen
es gibt also eine vor alle erfahrung
gültige sinnlichkeit und das ist erst
mal kontra intuitiv weil würde sagen
sinnlichkeit ist doch immer durch die
sinne vermittelt und insofern es durch
die sinne vermittelt ist ist es ab
postareal nein sagt und es gibt eine
form von ziemlich kite die nicht zum
verstand zu rechnen ist die aber dennoch
apriori ist und das ist die reine form
der sinnlichkeit die air france zentrale
ästhetik nennt es muss also eine solche
wissenschaft geben die den ersten teil
der trans and arlen elementar lehrer
ausmacht im gegensatz derjenigen welche
die prinzipien des freien denkens
enthält und transnet alle logik genannt
wird also kann hat da eine ganz große
architektonisch seiner kritik der reinen
vernunft die zerfällt in eine
transzendentale elementar lehre eine
trans en thale methodenlehre in eine
transzendentale logik an eine transall
thale ästhetik und eine transall thale
dialektik das braucht uns jetzt nicht
weiter zu interessieren hier sagt jetzt
jedenfalls die trans zentralen logik die
betrifft diese rahmungen von substanzen
kausalität die trans zentrale ästhetik
betrifft die rahmung von raum zeit also
die logik können sich so merken die
trans en thale logik trifft alles das
was wir logisch durchsetze ausdrücken
können durch urteile
dieser stuhl ist so und so das betrifft
die logik in dem sie von einem urteil
struktur zu grunde liegt da ist die
substanz stelle
da ist das prädikat diese grundstruktur
das betrifft die trendteile logik und
jetzt gibt eben noch die drei ästhetik
in dieser wer also werden wir zuerst die
sinnlichkeit isolieren dadurch dass wir
alles ab sondern was der verstand durch
seine begriffe dabei denkt zum beispiel
substanz kausalität usw
damit nichts als empirische anschauung
übrig bleiben als interessant empirische
anschauen wenn ich es recht verstehe
wäre hiermit noch ein bild zu zeigen
wenn wir jetzt hier das was der verstand
denkt absolut das heißt wenn wir
substanzen kausalität wegnehmen dann
haben wir noch härter farbe geruch und
ton plus raum und zeit haben wir noch
dass hier sozusagen das haben wir noch
das zu trinken und das nennt kann jetzt
empirische anschauen
bleibt uns übrig zweitens werden wir von
dieser noch alles was zur findung gehört
abtrennen damit nicht als reine
anschauen und die bloße formt
erscheinung übrig bleibe welche das ei
welches das einzige ist dass die
sinnlichkeit apriori liefern kann
so jetzt nehmen wir davon hier von
diesem was wir jetzt hier praktisch
eingekesselt haben noch das werk die
ganzen wird oder bleibt das übrig
zweiten raum als formel der sinnlichkeit
bei dieser untersuchung wird sich finden
das ist zwei reine formen der sinnliche
anschauung als prinzipien der erkenntnis
apriori gebe nämlich raum und zeit mit
deren erwägung wir uns jetzt zum ende
der sitzung beschäftigen wir die zeit
ist erstens kein empirischer begriff der
irgendwann einer erfahrung abgezogen
worden ist denn das zugleich sein oder
aufeinander folgen würde selbst nicht in
die wahrnehmung kommen wenn die
forschung derzeit nicht apriori zum
grunde lege nur unter deren
voraussetzung kann man sich vorstellen
dass einige es zu einer unter selben
zeit zugleich oder in verschiedenen
zeiten nacheinander sei wissen argument
ist dass jetzt sie sich noch da werden
zwei philosophen die dieses argument so
vertreten hat dass wir das er wechsele
letztendlich bewegung immer nur erklären
können wenn wir zeit voraussetzen dass
also zeit nicht nichts an der bewegung
ist und nicht die bewegung ist zurzeit
vorausgesetzt werden muss
aristoteles und auch ein youtube würde
ich sagen ja oder clark das ist so
angesagt ein bisschen diese objektivität
der zeit und als ganz interessant von
keine erfahrung abgezogenen kann zeit
muss vorausgesetzt werden um überhaupt
erfahrung machen zum wechsel bewegen usw
messen zu können
die zeit ist ja
draußen
ja genau ja kann führt dann sagen es ist
unser innerer sinn unser innerer sinn
weil wir letztendlich alles am ende auf
uns selbst beziehen und in diesem
beispiel was ich gebracht hatte wird es
sehr deutlich wenn wir uns zum beispiel
vorstellen dass wir jetzt unsere augen
schließen und alle sinnesorgane sagen
abdunkeln als den augen blende auf
ohrstöpsel reinlassen stürzl rein hände
so hände nichts an etwas hin fassen
lassen das heißt sie schließen schließen
alle sinneskanäle schließen sie und was
können sie ja noch machen ja dann können
sie noch eine mathematische operationen
machen können sie jetzt drei plus drei
zähler
und da würde kann sagen hier ist daneben
die reine erscheinungsform derzeit noch
thematisch auch wenn sie selbst keinen
raum mehr da vorbildlich haben sie sehen
ja nichts mehr
sie haben keine erfahrung von
räumlichkeit wenn sie zb in der
mathematik eine operation durchführen
nach kann haben sie es sind sie nur noch
in der zeit dem sie in der reinen
anschauungs form der zeit bestimmte
bestimmte zahlen oder bestimmte mengen
aufeinander reihen so stellt sich jetzt
eben kann die arithmetik vor wählen sie
jetzt hingegen geometrisch dächten in
dieser dunkelkammer geometrisch also ein
dreieck da sich konstruieren würden dann
wäre der raum wieder plötzlich im spiel
sein kann dann wäre die reine anschaust
form der des raumes im spiel bei
geometrie nur im raum nach cannstatt
wind kann wie es höchst problematisch
sie kamen alle in der schule analytische
geometrie gehabt bei uns überhaupt kein
raum analytische geometrie wenn sie da
vektoren haben
rektoren haben gar nichts mit dem raum
direkt zu tun sind einfach logische
beziehungen sind sind
es ist analytisch es nichts mehr was sie
in einer ebene machen sondern sie
setzten nur bestimmte funktionen ein
verhältnis sie beschreiben einen kreis
mit so einer funktion kommt überhaupt
nichts räumlich es mehr drin vor ob da
kann recht zu geben ist das ist die
spannende frage aber das ist schwierig
aber wir brauchen jetzt nicht auf solche
detail probleme einzugehen
jedenfalls die zeit ist wirklich ganz
ganz prominenten
ich habe auch anwendungen
oder
von
verständlich bei abhängig oder nicht
können wir ja auch mehr erkennen meinte
richtig das ist ein guter punkt sie
haben schon recht die bedingung der
möglichkeit von zeit erfahren würden wir
sagen auch mit einstein noch einer ein
anstoß von derzeit verdanken
nur wäre daneben und dessen mit gleich
noch bekannt nicht mehr die bedingung
der absoluten des absoluten verlaufs
gegeben
das moment der zeitlichkeit können wir
auch sagen bei einstellen auch so
formulieren trans zentral aber eben
nicht mehr dieses newtons im moment das
kann eben übernommen hat dass wale die
zeitgleich ist dass alle in derselben
zeit leben diese objektivität konnte das
nicht wissen die frage wer was er dann
gesagt hätte also zum beispiel karl
popper der dieser wissenschaft versucht
er hat es kann vorgeworfen wie gesagt
ganz trans en thale ist tätig sowohl
raum als auch zeit lässt sich mit
einsteins erkenntnissen nicht mehr
angemessen vereinbaren und gut was jetzt
nicht vereinbar ist sie nur nicht
vereinbaren die objektivität die sagen
der raum und zeit erfahrung aber dass
auch ein gekrümmter raum ein raum ist
und auch eine langsame verstrichene zeit
eine zeit ist da wäre dann kann rechts
ergeben also ein guter punkt sie haben
insofern recht als wir den trans and
arlen status derzeit durchaus mit kant
retten können aber bei kommt kommt eben
immer noch gespielt dass er mit trans
zentral objektiv meint und eben nicht
nur individuell gültig wer möchte wenn
ich ein recht verstehen mit dem trans
zentralen sagen es ist vor allem
erfahrung und es bedingt auch dass alle
die erfahrung gleich gemacht werden und
dieses objektive element des 20 zahlen
können wir eben dann mit einsteins
einsicht nicht mehr so retten
ja
sie haben schon recht es war für mich
ganz präzise von mir ausgedrückt also
halt vereins objekt was halt in einem
beschleuniger in dem raumschiff ist dass
sich fast mit lichtgeschwindigkeit
bewegen ein anderes was draußen steht da
mal eben vor allem individuum so eine
zeit und von anderes eine andere im
rheder in der relation für das eine
individuum verläuft die zeit einfach
langsamer und das wäre nach kant nicht
möglich nach seiner trans zentralen
auffassung trans zentral würde bedeuten
für beide individuen oder subjekte wo es
die selbe zeit taktung gelten
genau als einstellen denkt die zeit
einfach sehr stark nach newton verlagert
sie aber von der außenwelt gewissermaßen
in die reine anschauungs form der der
sinnlichkeit
das ist nach wie vor relevant ja genau
alle da das ist völlig richtig also es
gibt wie gesagt zwei momente einmal
diese reine apriori status den kann man
kann noch zugestehen auch angesichts der
erkenntnisse der relativitätstheorie nur
nicht mehr diesen streng optimistischen
trans zentralen status den eben nicht
mehr aber guter punkt da sie darauf
hinweisen
er zeigt er folgendes noch zweitens die
zeit ist eine notwendige vorstellung die
allen anschauung zum grunde liegt man
kann in ansehung der erscheinungen
überhaupt die zeit selbst nicht aufheben
ob man zwar ganz wohl die erscheinungen
aus der zeit wegnehmen kann das ist
jetzt eben gerade das hier
wir können diese x10 hier gegeben wir
können diesen weg nehmen
die zeit ist also a priori gegeben in
ihr allein wir können die x10 wegnehmen
aber wir können nicht die zeit wegnehmen
die zeit ist von anderer natur die zeit
ist eine rahmen innerhalb der dxs
vorkommt derzeit ist als abort jedem in
ihr allein ist alle wirklichkeit
erscheinung möglich diese könnten
insgesamt wegfallen die x10 aber sie
selbst die zeit als all die allgemeine
bedingungen ihre möglichkeit deckchen
oder erfahrung genauer gesagt kann nicht
aufgehoben werden
also sind es eindrücke können wir nach
kant dann wohl nur in der zeit machen dh
die sinneseindrücke selbst sind
eigentlich nicht zeitlich aber sie
bedürfen um auftreten zu können einer
form einer bühne sozusagen auf der sie
eben dann auftreten
das ist ganz interessant wer denkt ist
ganz stark in abstraktion modell was
können wir logisch denkt möglich ab
sondern was setzt was voraus ordnungs
und herrchen dritte bedingung auf diese
notwendigkeit apriori gründet sich die
möglichkeit apodiktische grundsätze von
den verhältnissen derzeit oder aktion
von derzeit überhaupt sie hat nur eine
dimension verschiedene zeiten sind nicht
zugleich sondern nacheinander also für
vier jahre später ist nicht so gleich
wie jetzt sagt er schon das wort
jetzt zeigt dass schon der begriff sie
hat nur eine dimension wie gesagt sind
nacheinander sowie verschiedene räume
nicht nacheinander sondern zugleich sind
also da der raum hier der raum 214 ist
zur selben zeit wie dieser raum hier 007
reservisten
also diese räume sind zur selben zeit
sind nicht alle teile des raumes müssen
wir genau sagt sind zur selben zeit also
genau andersrum wie in der zeit diese
grundsätze können aus der erfahrung
nicht gezogen werden
denn diese würde wieder strenger
allgemeinheit noch apodiktische
gewissheit geben würden nur sagen können
so lehrt es die gemeinde wahrnehmen
nicht aber so muss es sich verhalten
diese grundsätze gelten als regeln unter
denen überhaupt erfahrungen möglich ist
und belehren uns vor derselben und nicht
durch dieselbe und hier in diesem
letzten satz haben sie noch mal ganz
deutlich von kant dargelegt bekommen was
apriori etwas ab osterode bedeutet also
unter den überhaupt erfahrungen möglich
ist und belehren uns vor derselben das
ist das apriori das ist das trans
zentrale und nicht durch diese apostels
durch die erfahrung und apriori bedeutet
fort der fall
wir können wohl aussagen nach kann über
raum und zeit nicht auf basis der bloßen
sinneswahrnehmung machen
wir brauchen immer diese reihen
anschauungs form von raum und zeit
ich glaube bis dahin wollen wir es mal
belassen ich glaube wir brauchen jetzt
auch nicht weiter vielleicht nur ein
punkt noch hier
die zeit ist kein diskursiver beamer
oder wie man sagt allgemeiner begriff
sind eine reine form der sich anschauen
verschiedene zeiten sind nur teile eben
derselben zeit die vorstellung die durch
einen einzigen gegenstand gegeben werden
kann ist aber anschauen auch würde sich
der satz dass verschiedene zeit nicht
zugleich sein können aus einem
allgemeinen begriff nicht herleiten
lassen der satz ist synthetisch und kann
aus begriffen allein nicht entspringen
synthetisch bedeutet erst informativ des
gehalts erweitern und dadurch dass er
gehalts erweitert ist kein lose begriffs
analyse im begriff derzeit liegt das
nicht drin vielleicht dass der satz
synthetisch ist kann er nicht alleine
aus begriffen analytischen springen er
ist also in der anschaffung und forschen
derzeit um gebannt halten diese
synthetischen
also das ist das wir über die zeit nicht
grün sind der analyse eines begriffs
reden sind dass wir wenn wir von zeit
sprechen nach kann sowas eine
information bekommen dass die zeit
verschiedene zeiten nicht zur selben
zeit sein können
das wäre nach kann nichts was analytisch
ist ich hätte jetzt gedacht das ist ein
begriff der zeit enthalten aber kann
sagt nein inbegriff der zeit ist das
nicht enthalten sondern es ist in der
anschauungs form der zeit und hat
seitlich aussagen sind deswegen
synthetisch gehalts erweitern weil sie
nicht rein begrifflich sind sondern von
unsere anschauungs form abhängig sind
ein fünftes noch die unendlichkeit der
zeit bedeutet nichts weiter als dass
alle bestimmte größe derzeit nur durch
einschränkungen eine einigen zum grunde
liegenden zeit möglich sein
daher muss die ursprüngliche vorstellung
der zeit als uneingeschränkt gegeben
sein wovon aber die teile selbst und
jede größe eines gegenstandes nur durch
einschränkungen bestimmt vorgestellt
werden können da muss die ganze
vorstellung nicht durch begriffe gegeben
sein denn die enthalten urteil
vorstellen
sonst muss ihn unmittelbare anschauung
zum kunden liegen also hier gibt es so
ein bisschen das problem
das würde jetzt ein bisschen
wahrscheinlich mit einstein
konfigurieren
diese uneingeschränkt ein bisschen da
sich die objektivität bis dahin wo man
zwar belasten also sie haben jetzt
gesehen
zeit ist verkannt etwas was apriori ist
also vor einer erfahrung für die frage
wie können derzeit erkennen kann ist die
zeit ist nach kann kein gegenstand
unserer erkenntnis nicht objektiv
gegeben ist es ist dadurch aber noch
nicht gleich etwas was a priori im sinne
dieses verstandes ist sondern es ist
eine dritte realität sozusagen zeit
konzentriert und auch raum eine dritte
realität die etwas gemeinsam hat mit
diesen x4 mit der sinneswahrnehmung als
sie mit unserer sinnlichkeit zu tun hat
unsere sinneswahrnehmung arbeiten
wiederum auf der anderen seite etwas mit
unserem verstand zu tun hat als sie vor
alle erfahrung gilt und nur durch also
nur durch diese zeit überhaupt erfahrung
möglich ist zeit ist also ein
zwischending zwischen verstand und
sinneswandel irgend so ein drittel
realität und das ist glaube ich sehr
verdienstvoll dass kann diese realität
als solche mal versucht hat zu
exportieren und dadurch könnte man sagen
es kann zu einer art zwischen stellung
auch zwischen newton und lockt und und
leibnitz ein newton hatte er im
puristische vorstellung von zeit
behauptet jetzt mal es gibt halt diese
absolute zeit die gibt es halt in der
natur wahrscheinlich der natur die gibt
es halt die verläuft halt einfach wie so
einfluss in der natur gleichmäßig läuft
die eben auch die zeit also sehr
empirisch gedacht auch objektiv
natürlich und dann leibnitz der die zeit
sehr logisch gedacht hatte also zeit ist
etwas was allein aus so interpretiere
ich ihn jetzt aus kausalen relationen
von dingen besteht es ist dann zeit sehr
rational gedacht und kann möchte einfach
beides zusammenbringen sagt zeit hat
einerseits empirische oder eine
sinnliche seite muss man sagen das
einstellungs form holen sie hat zugleich
was rationales insofern sieht vor allem
liegt das in aller kürze zu kant und in
der nächsten sitzung gehen wir auf
friedrich wilhelm joseph schelling 1
und zwar auf seine schrift die bild
alter und da werden sie jetzt glücklich
sehen dass die ekstasen derzeit also
dass die fahrer also vergangenheit
gegenüber zukunft plötzlich eine
aufwertung erfährt die so in der
philosophie noch nie gegeben hat so wir
haben jetzt bekannt gesehen dass die a3
praktisch keine rolle spielt er spricht
er nie von zukunft von vergangenheit und
vergeben war das also kann scheint mir
hier so eine ganz klare bereit zu denken
er möchte nur die objektivität der beere
bekunden in ihrem transporter anstatt
uns die arbeit spielt keine runde und
bei schelling sehen wir jetzt dass diese
gewichtung plötzlich sich umdrehte und
die ahr eine ganz ganz große bedeutung
gewinnt weil er aus dieser schrift
gelesen werden ein titel hat und der
titel dieser schrift und dieses kapitels
lautet die vergangenheit glauben und
über die zukunft es hat wirklich so
ausdrücken titel ausdruck der aus der
technologie der ara und das führt dann
natürlich weiter zu den nächsten
philosophen die wir behandeln werden zu
heiliger am ende aber auch schon davor
zu berg song an das ima reihen
qualitäten von zeiten plötzlich eine
objektive bedeutung bekommen und nicht
mehr nur irgendwas zu abstrahieren das
ist was von den kontingenten subjekt
abhängig das hängt natürlich mit der
aufwertung der individuellen existenz im
zuge der existenz philosophie das
nützlich vermeintlich äußerlich
eigenschaften wie zukünftig skype von
einem bestimmten gebundenen standpunkt
aus dass die plötzlich die oberhand
gewinnen gegenüber rein objektiv ist
ischen beschreibung nachdem ihre dann
bis zur nächsten sitzung